if you're curious about the long-awaited
three quilt of bad boys and some of the
drama surrounding it look no further
here's everything you need to know
before you sit down to watch some
massive explosions and ridiculous action
scenes it just wouldn't be a bad boys
film if it weren't for the bad boys
themselves Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence obviously both Smith and
Lawrence are returning in their
franchise roles as detectives Mike
Lowrey and Marcus Burnett and they're
still using extreme measures to combat
some of the worst crime in Miami if you
need a refresher Will Smith's character
Mike Lowrey is the rich ladies man of
the team while Lawrence's Marcus Burnett
is more the exasperated family man
together they're the bad boys of the
Miami Police Department there's one
other crucial ass back to the bad boys
franchise and that's the irritated and
grudgingly respectful captain Howard
luckily Joe Pantoliano will also be
returning in bad boys for life we're
guessing that time hasn't changed how
fed up he is with our favorite
detectives even if he always ends up
having their backs anyway I have three
cops critical I got kids dying on my
streets from souped-up X I do not want
these animals taking over my city we
know a bit of the story going into bad
boys for life thanks to some official
production notes and the trailers
released so far the story focuses on a
mo an elite squad within the Miami
Police Department their current target
is Armando our MAS a violent young
cartel leader our mas has his crosshairs
focused on detective Lowery and he has
prior history with our heroes with our
mas on the hunt Lowery and Burnett are
pulled back into the fray despite the
fact that Burnett seems to have his eye
on retirement they start working with a
mows leader to stop the threat our
mosque poses naturally ammos leader is
also a former flame of Detective
Lowery's and he considers her the one
that got away most of the actors showing
up in bad boys for life are new to the
franchise but there's a pretty good mix
of up-and-coming actors in well
establishments the big one joining the
cast is Jacob Scipio who will portray
Armando our MAS the film's villain his
character is described as having a
vicious taunting nature and he has a
past connection with our detectives
Callen Nunez a star of Mexican
television and film is also joining bad
boys for life as Mike's ex a criminal
psychologist and the a prevention head
vamo we also know a few actors will play
roles as members of this elite squad
Vanessa Hudgens Alexander Ludwig and
Charles Melton will all be part of the
team it's a bad boys film so it probably
isn't much of a stretch to guess that at
least one of them is a secret bad guy
finally one interesting wrinkle in the
plot description is that our mas targets
our heroes under the direction of his
mother we don't know for sure who plays
this character but kate del Castillo who
has been cast in an undisclosed role
seems like a good bet it seems like all
the elements for a bad boys film are
here the bad boys for life is missing
one significant piece Michael Bay
instead the directing duo of LDL Bahrain
and Bilal Villa are at the helm they
previously directed black gangsta and
also have signed on to direct Beverly
Hills Cop 4 they may not have been the
first choices to take on bad boys for
life but they were the ones who managed
to get the troubled production to the
finish line why did it take so long for
a third bad boys movie to explode onto
the screen well the project had to sail
some troubled waters Will Smith
reportedly had a sequel in mind since at
least 2008 but multiple delays had many
people thinking it may never happen at
all the original director was going to
be joe carnahan who's helmed big action
movies like smokin aces and the a-team
however Carnahan apparently clashed with
Will Smith about the creative direction
of bad boys for life and was
subsequently let go from the project
it's unclear what exactly caused the
rift but Carnahan is still credited as a
co-writer on the film's screenplay
considering all the talk in the trailer
of this being the last ride for our
detective bureaus it seems likely that
bad boys for life is the end of their
story however if they decide to ever
truly reboot the bad boys franchise one
Hollywood actor has already thrown his
name in the ring to take up the reins
Winston Duke who played in Baku and
black panther and starred in Jordan
peels us told the deadline podcast that
he would love to star if they ever
rebooted bad boys he also offered Black
Panther co-star Daniel Kaluga as the
person he would choose to partner up
with if it ever did get off the ground
considering the timing it seems unlikely
that a bad boys
reboot will happen anytime soon but the
prospect of Duke and Kaluga teaming up
is a great idea nonetheless with all the
years that have passed since bad boys -
you're probably eager to see some things
blow up already
the trailers released so far have pretty
much everything you could want Lowry
exasperated at Burnett's antics check I
got this I'm gonna penetrate this man's
soul with my heart what captain Howard's
swearing a whole bunch check a bunch of
people singing bad boys by inner circle
ah yes and of course the explosions so
many explosions you'll be able to see
them all when the film blasts in the
theaters on January 17th 2020 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]